soccer balls RC cars and a whole lot of
nitro sounds like a recipe for success
and for psionics is indie hit rocket
League it certainly is it launched in
July on PC and as a PS plus free be here
we are at the end of the year and it's
generated nearly 50 million dollars
score the wall street journal reported
rocket leagues big bucks also pointing
out the game's eight million registered
users rocket League was developed in two
years on a budget of just under 2
million during that time the team at
psionics also did contract work on the
mass effect and Gears of War series with
those profit margins it seems like time
well spent psionics chief Dave hegwood
said the goal was to get rocket League
into as many hands as possible hence the
initial release on PS plus with free
copies in hand twitch broadcasters and
youtubers alike built up the buzz around
the game looks like the plan worked
rocket League is one of 2015's great
video game success stories and it's not
done yet rumor has it that KITT from
Knight Rider may be making an appearance
soon if he does he'll definitely hear
about it from gamespot
you